Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
it's still not that dim and
we're still not at the table
because we're still at our own homes.
How do you think the table is doing?
How long is this gonna last?
The table's just sitting
in there in the studio,
just being a table.
Oh, I'm sure it's doing fine.
Yeah, it's doing good, man.
It's lonely, sadly, like a
lot of people these days.
Don't mean to start on the downer.
We are gonna talk about the silver lining.
We're gonna try to be positive,
and we're gonna look to the future.
And what type of impact is
this experience going through,
weathering this virus,
what lasting effects is it gonna have?
What ripple effects is it gonna have?
How is it gonna impact the
future of our lives indefinitely?
And like you said, I
think in a positive way,
'cause I mean, one of the things
that has been helpful for me
as I get anxious, get fearful,
get frustrated with the fact that we're
cooped up in the house is to think
about the good that will come from this.
And I do, I think there's gonna be,
there's quite a bit, there's
quite a bit to be excited
about in terms of the future.
It's growing pains.
Yeah, I've got
a number of thoughts
related to different categories.
As I'm adapting to this new lifestyle
of staying at home with
my immediate family,
I'm starting to take note of things.
It's like, wow, this is,
this is different, but it's not worse.
This is better.
I wonder if I'm gonna keep this habit
even after things change.
So, you know, I've got a number of things
that I'll bring up.
And then, you know what?
This can serve as kind of
like a time capsule episode
where we go back to 'em
and we see how right or wrong we were.
Do you have any bold predictions
that you're prepared to make?
Well, my prediction is that at some point
I won't be in the corner of my living room
making this podcast, as is
evidenced just by the fact
that right at the beginning
of this recording,
when I got, which I had to
do every time we get ready
to do anything in here, is I'm like,
"Okay, guys, I'm recording."
And then the thing that came back,
one person said,
Noice.
I think my wife said,
"Can't we live our lives?"
And then I think my son said,
"Why don't you do this in the garage?"
So again, the family has still not adapted
to what's happening, even though,
I mean, I hate to drive this point home--
And you're not talking
about the virus anymore.
You're talking about your job,
being in their faces.
Interestingly, you know,
my job is actually an important part
of the family dynamic.
Last time I checked.
Now, my wonderful,
beautiful wife is standing
at the top of the steps down
into our sunken living room
and just staring at me incredulously
because she's listening.
She looks great.
She's got her Jason Isbell shirt on
that has a dinosaur on it.
Why are you reducing her to
only what she looks like?
Well, I'm not doing that.
I just know, I know what she likes.
I know how she likes me to talk about her.
I love you.
I love all of you.
You're all great.
Now, go away.
Well, one of the things that I have been,
that has been an immediate change for me
is the way that we're approaching food.
I think this is the case for
people all over the world.
Now, we are in a very privileged position
because we still have access
to all the food that we
want essentially, right?
You may not get as many things
as readily as you got them in the past
and we're making do
with a little bit more.
We're cooking for ourselves a
lot more than we normally do.
We're eating leftovers which,
this is gonna sound pretty privileged,
but most of the leftovers at our house
get eaten by the adults.
I'll eat leftovers.
My kids are spoiled rotten, man.
If another day comes, the next day comes
and we're like, "We're having leftovers,"
the look of grief and disappointment
on my children's faces
is just a sign that
they're spoiled rotten.
But now--
We would have a night--
We don't have a choice at this point.
We would have a night of the week
that would be leftover night,
and we tried to make it
into something that
seemed more like an event.
Like Christy would say things
like, "It's leftover night,"
you know, and you're just like--
How did that go over?
Am I supposed to cheer?
It's not usually cheers.
No.
But yeah, now there's
a heightened sense of,
okay, there's a little bit of this left.
I'ma Tupperware that thing
up and I'ma put it away.
And then you're, 'cause
you just don't know
when you're gonna get some of that
from the grocery store again.
Like a little bit of, we had,
I mean, we are occasionally
ordering takeout.
It's a stressful time.
Especially after that video
that Ellie sent around.
Ellie shared a video,
and there's this one doctor,
I guess he's in Seattle, who,
he's had a few videos go viral,
but he talks about what you should do
when you bring groceries home
and when you bring takeout home.
And I shared that video with
our friend chat group, which
Jessie, of course, is in.
And she was like, "You
cannot share this video
"with someone who has OCD,
"because they will just
go down this rabbit hole."
So I said, okay--
And never come back.
I'll be the one to be responsible
for the disinfection process
when things come to the door.
It's very stressful.
It's one thing when
you've got like a couple,
like two bags of carryout,
but it's another thing
when you order groceries and they show up.
Like yesterday, we had groceries
show up, which, by the way,
we had ordered probably
five or six days in advance.
And so you're trying to figure out
what you're gonna be out
of, and you're gonna,
you're trying to figure out,
well, if they don't have this,
then they're gonna try to substitute.
If they don't have anything,
I'm trying to get something
else just so we got,
we have well-rounded meals.
Now Christy handled that order,
but I knew how stressful it would be
when all that was dropped off at the door.
I was like, I'll be on the front lines
of kinda bringing this stuff in.
And you know, we got this whole system.
Like, we clean off the counter
and then you bring it in
and you put all the bags on the floor.
and you take the stuff out of the bags
and you put 'em in a unsanitized pile,
throw away the bags, and then
spray down and then wipe down
every square inch of
everything that's pre-packaged
that's potentially been handled
that's coming into the house.
I mean, it's a, you know,
it was a lot of groceries,
so it was for five people,
so it was like a half-hour
process to get this thing done.
And it's very stressful
because you start to feel like,
you start to feel like you're exiting
some sort of nuclear contamination zone.
To me, that's one of the first things
I've been thinking about,
is as much as I overthink everything,
now I've been thinking about
the level of contagion,
how easily things can be spread
and all the things that I'm touching.
So I mean, this is, I'm sure,
a common experience to a lot of people,
and I just don't know
if that's gonna go away
when this virus is in the past, you know.
Am I gonna be a fist bumper?
Am I gonna be a, am I gonna be somebody
who brings in the groceries
and wipes them down?
I don't think I'll be
wiping all the groceries.
No, because that would be irrational.
I mean--
Oh, I know,
but I will be thinking
about it more often.
I mean, like not handshaking
or touching people
for such a long time.
Well, yeah.
Let's wait.
Let's wait to get into
that because I think
that there's a whole
conversation we can have about
like what this means
about proximity to people
and greetings and stuff.
But going back to the groceries, I mean,
the first thing I will say,
because I don't wanna alarm people,
I don't want people to
think that the process
that you just outlined is
necessary for everybody
because, you know, most of the research,
the research suggests that the
virus does not easily spread
through takeout food or through groceries.
But that doesn't mean
that there isn't a risk.
It just means that it's
significantly lower a risk
than actually being in
the proximity of somebody
who is infected and breathing in
like an actual, you know, droplet
that's in the air.
Droplet.
But that doesn't mean that
there isn't some risk.
So if you wanna eliminate the
risk or minimize the risk,
then you can go the extra mile.
Not doing, you sound like you're doing
exactly what the guy
described in the video.
He got all the way down--
Yeah, once you send me the video,
I'm gonna do exactly what's in the video.
Yeah, but he was washing
each piece of fruit
for 20 seconds with soap.
You're not doing that, are you?
Christy handled that stuff,
so I don't know if she went that far.
We're just being--
Probably did though.
We're trying to leave the external bags
and we're doing takeout
like once to twice a week.
We're trying to minimize that.
But leaving those external
bags on the porch,
and then when you can kinda empty out
the contents of a package onto a plate
or something like that and
then throwing away that
and wiping everything down,
sticking to hot foods
instead of cold foods,
it, I just, what I'm trying to do
is mitigate it, minimize it,
but knowing that you can't
really eliminate the risk.
But I mean, the thing that
scares me more than anything
is if I have to be in close
proximity with somebody,
which I really haven't.
The only, during this,
and so we're recording this on,
what is it, the 31st of March
when we're actually recording this?
Yeah.
And so obviously, you're
still in lockdown.
Lockdown's been, sort
of a federal lockdown
has been pushed through the end of April.
California will probably
go longer than that.
I saw that the governor of Virginia
said there was gonna be a
lockdown through June 10th,
subject to be updated.
But he went ahead and said to June 10th,
a stay at home order, basically.
The only thing that I've done
is there was that one time
I had to go over to the creative house
to accept the delivery of a desk.
My desk finally came in.
And I met the guy--
How'd that go?
Well, I met the guys out
in the front and I stayed,
I was like 20 feet from
these dudes outside.
And I was like, "All right,
guys, here's what I'm gonna do.
"I'm going to describe to you,
"I'm gonna go inside, I'm
gonna open up the doors
"and leave them open so you can walk in.
"I'm gonna come back out.
"I'm gonna describe to you the room
"and the location that I want
this desk to be set up in.
"And then I'm gonna go into the backyard
"and I'm going to wait."
So in other words, I don't wanna be
in the same house at the same time.
Because I've been doing good
about this quarantine thing.
And now, first of all, they,
the two guys who were delivering
and setting up the desk volunteered,
they were like, "Well, we don't have it."
And I was like, I didn't say anything,
like, "Well, you're typically asymptom-,
"you could be the 25% or more of people
"who are asymptomatic, who have
it but are still contagious.
"Or you could be the 100% of people
"who usually get the disease and have it,
"are asymptomatic for the first two days
"but also are contagious."
But I didn't break that out.
I didn't wanna be that guy.
It's frustrating that it's just
not getting through to people.
Well, that's another
thing we'll talk about,
is people's inability or unwillingness
to process the facts around this stuff.
But anyway, so I said all that,
and then I'm in the backyard
and the guy, he's like, "Sir."
And I'm like, "Oh, no,
they've run into a problem."
And I kinda like stick my
head into the living room
and I can see in the hallway,
and I can see that they've got the desk
sort of like stood up and they're like,
"This desk is not going to fit into,
"we can't get it in
there," and he was like,
"I've been doing this for 13 years."
At that point,
It ain't gonna happen.
I took a deep breath.
And you told him to
just put it in my room.
Well, actually, no, no--
It's a nice desk.
No, I explored this option.
I was gonna do this
without your permission.
Oh, yeah?
I was gonna put my desk in your room
and just switch our offices
and see if you ever noticed.
But it's not the location of my office,
it's the width of the
doors in the creative house
are 29 inches, which are too
small to get anything in there.
So you're, there's no
room that it could fit in
except the living room, so
I told him to take it back.
But before I told him to take
it back, I went up to them,
I held my breath and
walked into the house.
You know I can hold my
breath for quite some time.
I had a conversation without breathing,
which I have been practicing lately.
Which we've discussed, yes.
And I was like, okay,
by the time I was running out of breath,
I was like, "All right, you're right.
"I don't think this is gonna fit.
"Just return it," and then ran outside.
You ran outside?
Yeah.
It's like your face is turning blue.
I probably did breathe
inside a little bit so,
but you know, that was a week ago
and I'm still feeling okay.
Anyway--
I mean,
I get as much delivered as possible,
but I ordered takeout from this one place
and I went to pick it up.
And I had done this before
and you know, you go in
and they've got a rack
and your stuff's on it.
We've already paid.
There's no touching the credit cards
or even signing of anything.
You just take it.
But some people, they're not,
they haven't figured all that out.
So I get there and it's
like, I gotta sign a thing.
I'm not, I didn't wanna sign a thing.
And I'm touching this pen.
Yeah, what the hell?
Why are they, what is
wrong with people, man?
I don't understand why they
can't get with the program.
Figure it out.
And then, even worse,
they have this coffee bar,
and that's where you went
to pick up the stuff,
but there was a guy sitting--
You should have just said,
"I'm not signing it," by the way.
Say, "Screw it.
"What are you gonna do, sue me?
"I'm not signing it."
I signed it and I had
my antibacterial spray,
and I immediately sprayed
myself and walked out
and sprayed myself again,
sprayed my hand, you know, but--
Sprayed myself.
There was a guy
who had gotten coffee, and they gave it
to him in a to-go mug,
and then he sat down in the aisle
where everyone has to pick up.
And he's like just within
a few feet of people,
and he's an older guy.
And he's talking to
everybody that comes in
because, I don't know,
maybe he lives alone.
He's probably lonely.
He just sat there.
And they should have
told him he had to leave.
And here I am, I'm like, am
I the one to tell this guy,
"Sir, you really don't need to be here
"for your health and the
health of other people.
"Everyone has to come in
too close proximity to you
"and you're talking."
What's the word when you
like, you boom your voice?
Projecting.
You're projecting.
You're projecting your voice
so that people can hear you
at a distance, which is projecting
stuff into the air, man.
It's like--
Well, just to give you an idea--
This is why I didn't talk to the guy,
because if I started talking to him,
I didn't wanna get angry with him.
So I didn't say anything.
Well, and so there might
be people who think that,
and we're gonna talk about this.
There might be people
Just talk about it.
Who think that we're overreacting,
that we're overreacting, that
the experts are overreacting.
But just to give,
what you're talking about with
the projecting of the voices.
So did you hear about the
chorus group that got together?
60 people got together--
No.
Like, you know, a week or two ago.
I don't know, before
everyone really understood,
maybe two, three weeks ago,
before anyone really understood
the seriousness of what was going on.
They got together for one practice
in a room, all singing, 60 people.
45 of them have tested
positive for COVID-19.
Being in the same room with
people who are talking,
much less singing--
Projecting and singing.
Just breathing is a risk.
It's like, this is,
again, this is not, this isn't,
it is not rocket science.
It is science, but it isn't a mystery.
It's not a surprise.
Because people are like,
"We didn't know this was gonna happen.
"We don't, this is a surprise
how quickly it's spreading."
No, it is not.
People have been talking
about it the whole time.
Why are we so surprised?
So all right, let's take a short break.
And it's scary.
I just wanna get the
scary part out of the way
so that on the backside of this break,
we can be more positive,
because now I'm worked up.
I know with some of the
stuff we're gonna talk about,
we're gonna get worked up again.
Oh, I'm gonna get worked up.
You know I'm gonna get worked up.
There's people dying.
I mean, you know, Joe Diffie is dead, man.
Right.
Poor guy.
You know, it's like,
I have a lot of good
memories to Joe Diffie songs.
I actually felt really
sad, you know, it's like--
But he does have, he has
the quintessential song
about what to do to him
after he dies, though.
Prop me up beside the jukebox when I die.
I wanna go to heaven, but
I don't wanna go tonight.
The main thing that I
thought about is the fact
that I just don't feel as
prepared as Joe Diffie.
Are they gonna do that to him?
Are they gonna, is he
currently propped up beside,
put some, put a stiff drink in my hand,
fill my boots up with sand.
Sadly, and I'm not joking,
I know it seems that we're making light
of Joe Diffie's death, we're not.
I think the reason that
it's not gonna happen
is because of this damn virus.
It's like if he had died in
another way during normal times,
they might actually be
considering that, but there's no,
you can't have a funeral.
You can't.
You can't have a funeral.
I mean--
You can have an online funeral.
When you talk about famous people
that you're fond of dying,
I mean they're heart-wrenching,
tragic stories.
I just can't bring myself
to read about 'em anymore,
of people's loved ones passing away.
And it's, you know, let's not get into it,
but it's scary, and it's
taking too long to sink in,
and it's taking,
again, two weeks ago, it was said
by the people who were
trying to get it to sink in,
it's not gonna happen
until people start dying,
until people you love start dying.
Yeah, that's what it
takes for some people.
We have this disconnect.
You know, I operate under
this disconnect a lot.
It's like you watch the news
and you hear about bad stories
and it's like that stuff
happens to other people.
It doesn't happen to me.
It doesn't happen to people.
It must be a defense mechanism,
because I'd like to think
I'm not the only one
who has that tendency.
We talked about it some last week but--
I think there's a number of reasons
and we can--
There's a number of reasons.
But I do think there are some positives,
we'll get into that.
We will get positive.
But first, we're gonna
get positive right now
'cause we're gonna let you know
that we are continuing to sell the 3D--
BYMB shirt.
Be Your Mythical Best shirt,
with a portion of the proceeds
going to Feeding America.
And Link, do you have the copy
for what Feeding America is doing?
I had it, but my computer's
having so many problems,
I had to shut the program
that had that information
about what Feeding America
is specifically doing
during the outbreak.
Feeding America is a
nationwide network of 200,
I can't even read numbers.
Oh, god.
Wow.
I said 200 food banks
working to ensure our most
vulnerable populations
continue to have access to food.
And their greatest need right now
is donations and support
of local food banks.
So yeah, the t-shirt
benefits Feeding America.
You can also donate yourself, so.
Mythical.com.
So how do we wanna get
into some positivity?
I wanna talk a little
bit about just this idea
of conservation and how
that applies personally
and what that might mean for the world--
Oh, you're talking about leftovers?
Yeah, well, I'm not going back
to that specifically, but I
am saying that it has made,
the scarcity or at least
the perceived scarcity
of some of these goods,
toilet paper for who knows why
being one of the chief ones that there's
a perceived scarcity of toilet paper,
that's not actually true,
there's just a few people
who have it all.
And I don't think they've got
especially dirty buttholes,
I just think they got panicked.
This perceived scarcity
has changed the way
that I approach my meals,
but also the amount
of toilet paper I do use, paper towels,
like the McLaughlin family, we can go
through a sapling's worth of paper towels
in a meal sometimes, just a disregard
for how much we are consuming.
And this is a problem in America,
this is a problem in the Western world,
but the thing is is that as these
developing nations become industrialized
and they kind of move into
this consumer-based culture,
they're all consuming
at the same rate, right.
We know that's a problem.
The Earth has been sort
of shouting for a while,
like, "This is a problem,
there's not enough.
"if you're all gonna act this way."
But it makes me think, as
I was trying to evaluate
what's this doing to me personally,
I was thinking about Jessie's grandmother
who died last year, I think she was 92.
So she was basically born
right around the time
of the Depression and she had
this tendency to be incredibly,
like she would conserve in
ways that we would laugh at.
Like she would put aluminum
foil over some food,
and then she would serve
it and then she would take
the aluminum foil off,
and she would wash it,
and she would fold it back up
and put it back in the drawer.
I mean this woman used aluminum
foil over and over again.
In fact, one time, one Christmas
her sister, Aunt Betty,
got her aluminum foil,
or tin foil as we called it
in the South, for Christmas.
It's like that was your Christmas present.
And those things that seem--
So that she could throw
it away more readily
or just because?
Just 'cause she knows
how much she values it,
it's just like toilet paper
has become currency.
I haven't bought anything
with toilet paper.
You could, try it.
I could?
If you draw
a picture of George Washington
on it, it'll definitely work.
But yeah, just this idea that it's like,
hmm, there is a limited amount of stuff.
But not just that, but I think
it draws into focus for me
this idea that the steady stream of goods
is always going to be there.
Like we took it for granted,
that everything that we need
is always going to be there,
you don't have to stock
up, you don't have to have
extra of anything, you don't have to be
prepared for anything.
Now you know me and being a prepper light,
I do have quite a bit of stuff ready.
But it's not lifestyle stuff.
Yeah, but it's like
emergency, I haven't gone
into any of it yet 'cause it's
just liked freeze-dried food.
But do you think, so you're
saying that you think
this will affect your
lifestyle moving forward?
I think it will and I think it will,
my hope, is that it will
change the way our kids.
The only people who really
have a sense of this
are probably boomers,
'cause they were at least
they can kind of remember
a time where things
were a little bit less
available, but they've all
bought into the same lie
that we've all bought into
that we can get whatever
we want whenever we want it
and damn the consequences.
It doesn't matter what
that means about people.
it means about the Earth.
But I think we're beginning to see that,
no, there's consequences
to that hyperconsumerism.
Not just this idea of
conservation as a, well,
I don't know if it's gonna be there,
but just beginning to examine,
hold on, it's not just
that the supply chains
are susceptible to things like a virus.
It's not that the fact that
we've got a global economy
and we're getting our
stuff from other places
that then could be affected,
and we're all interdependent,
and we're susceptible to
certain things, that's all true.
But it just makes, for me
there's been a few things
throughout this that have
just kinda begun to seem
a little gross and one
of them is this idea
that we can have whatever
we want, as much of it
as we want whenever we want.
It just seems like an irresponsible idea.
But if it doesn't get practical,
it's not gonna take hold.
I think it has to come down to, okay,
I'm out of paper towels.
I cannot get more paper towels.
So I'm gonna start using hand towels
and then I'm gonna put 'em in the laundry.
We have a few rolls of paper towels left
and I'm thinking about
just taking 'em out.
'Cause we have hand towels.
And once you discover a hand
towel works just as good
as a paper towel, it's just,
especially if you're a
kid and you're not the one
laundering the hand towels,
there's no impact to you.
Except now that I've wiped up this thing,
or I've wiped my hands, or whatever,
I don't know where to put it.
Well, you need to hang
it up and let it dry
and you can use it again.
You don't have to just throw it away.
So it's really just a habit.
And it's once you exchange
to doing the hand towels
and you get used to it for
a few weeks or a few months,
I think at that point then you can say,
"You know what, let's not go back."
I'm using much less toilet paper.
I'm using my bidet to a whole new level.
Oh, the bidet is the smartest thing
I've ever bought in my life.
But I realized how much
toilet paper I was still using
in combination with my bidet.
And I'm like, you know what,
I shouldn't have to use
two squares, and that's just
to dab off, just to dry off.
There is an air dryer,
but it takes forever.
Takes too long, and it
doesn't really work that well.
It also kind of sends toilet
stank throughout your room.
I think when you,
it can't be an ideological change of mind,
it has to be a habitual change of mind,
and I think as the weeks
go on, that's what will
make the difference.
But then I think there's, and
I think that's a positive.
I think another positive when I'm talking
about the groceries
coming in and I'm talking
about how stressful
that is and everything,
but I'm also thinking, you know what,
it took me 30 minutes
to wipe everything down,
but in the long run, when this is over,
I'm not gonna be wiping anything down,
and by the way, how
long would it have taken
to shop for all these groceries
that I just spent all
this time wiping down
if they weren't delivered to me?
I saved all of that time.
Man, grocery delivery's pretty nice.
Even if I don't get exactly
what I want, they swap it out
with something else, and there's
a little bit of a surprise.
You don't know exactly
what you're gonna get.
Ooh, look at what I got today.
It feels like I'm going back
to a milkman experience, man.
I always wondered what that would be like.
Ooh, look, the milkman's here, I wonder
what kinda milk I got.
Is it strawberry, is it chocolate?
Did they do that?
I don't think so.
I think it was mostly just milk.
Unless your milkman was a Nesquik rabbit.
Mine wasn't, 'cause I never had one.
There's some people who I know they do
the grocery delivery, but
the vast, vast, vast majority
of people don't do that.
You go and you shop for
your groceries, because,
well you know, I'll remember
something else that I need,
or this will strike my fancy.
But we're actually learning,
even with so many things
being swapped out that we
got a crap ton of groceries
come yesterday and it's
gonna last us a few weeks,
'cause we're trying to minimize the amount
of touchpoints that we
have with new deliveries.
I think that's something
that's gonna keep going.
The way that shopping has moved to Amazon
over the past five years,
whenever I want something the
first thing I think is Amazon,
except for groceries.
And I think this is
putting me over the edge
to have groceries delivered.
So I think that's another silver lining.
I find that somewhat problematic.
The whole Amazon thing,
you know, Amazon has its own issues
that it's dealing with.
I think that any major company like that
that is trying to serve that many people
and do it for profit.
I'm not saying order from Amazon,
I'm saying order from
your local grocery store.
I'm saying that habit,
I think, will continue.
But I'm saying you have to evaluate
that may make your life
easier and it may get you
off of the road, but it is also putting
a delivery person on the road meaning that
from a carbon standpoint,
I don't know, I've never looked into this,
I don't know which one is mo-
I think one of the things
is like I have a tendency,
for instance, when I
order stuff from Amazon,
as I think of it, I'll just order it
and it's one trip, it's one box,
whereas there's a more
responsible way to do that
to put things into a larger order.
Just that's a small thing that then, okay,
I can make this one trip
from one delivery person
as opposed to three or four.
But I do think that some of the--
But what I'm asking is what,
we're really talking
about what in the future,
how are our future
lives gonna be different
because of this experience?
And I'm just saying I'm gonna be ordering
a bunch of things that
I didn't order before.
I think groceries is
the chief amongst those.
Well, let's talk about
what you were talking
about earlier which is,
we can get back more
into the societal, financial,
sciencey stuff in a
second, but the greeting,
the idea of greetings.
Now obviously at some point,
I don't think I'll ever
go back to a handshake.
Just to put it simply.
Well, and 'cause there is
an acceptable alternative for it.
But before we get to
the handshakes, though,
just the idea of being in closed
spaces with people, right.
I mean one of the things
that I've been noticing
as I watch television and
I see groups of people,
like crowded places, I can't help
but think about the virus.
Now that's gonna go away,
like we're not gonna be
a species that no longer gathers together
in public spaces.
But I mean this particular,
depending on who you talk to,
and there's a range of predictions,
but this is probably going to be something
that subsides a little bit over the summer
and then comes back again in the fall.
It looks like it's gonna
have some seasonality to it.
We're not gonna have a
vaccine by the fall, I doubt.
I mean that would be an
unprecedented timeline,
maybe that'll happen.
But it doesn't look it will
and so we may actually be
dealing with it even a year after that.
So this particular virus may be something
that affects public gatherings
for 18 to 24 months.
But I think eventually
when we get past this,
we're gonna be thinking
differently about it,
but the thing is, and
again, comparisons between--
Here's how I'm gonna be
thinking differently about it.
I'm not gonna shake hands.
I'm not gonna be touching railings.
Like all the stuff that everybody touches,
I'm gonna have an instinct
to not touch those things
because now I have an
appreciation for how easily things
can be on, how germs can be on there.
Like I'm gonna be more
of a germaphobe, man.
I think I'm just gonna
have my hand in my sleeve
and I'm gonna be opening doorknobs.
I already whenever I would push on a door,
I would think about the
place where the least
number of people push,
especially children.
So I'll reach really high
and then push on a door.
Oh yeah, I do that all the time.
I've been doing that for years.
But I couldn't even tell you
exactly why I was doing it.
I was like, yeah, 'cause a
lot of people touch there
and that's gross.
But I hadn't really made the connection
that now is firmly in place
that's there is something there
that then will be on me that
then will go in my mouth.
I'm Howie Mandel-ing this thing, man.
Well but the question is is that--
I don't think I'm ever
gonna go all the way back.
But my question is if
everyone began to beh-,
I'm split on this, because
I feel like if everyone
behaves in this hypervigilant
way during normal times,
not now, but during normal times,
everybody's using hand
sanitizer, everybody's avoiding
each other, nobody's talking,
I mean nobody's touching,
nobody's shaking hands,
nobody's touching doorknobs
and stuff like that, everybody's putting
hand sanitizer on every surface.
I need to talk to an expert
on this, but my thought is
that that may make us
as a species long term
more susceptible to things.
I mean one of the reasons that when,
if you read "Guns, Germs, and
Steel," one of the reasons
that when the Western Europeans
when they came to America,
very few of them died and many
of the Native Americans died
was because--
'Cause the Native Americans
did not have doorknobs.
Yeah, they had been living
in these open spaces
and they weren't crowded together,
but all the Western
Europeans had been in cities
and gathered together so they had
all this resistance to viruses.
We're gonna keep, these
viruses are gonna keep coming.
You're gonna have a lot
more deaths from falling
because people aren't
gonna be using handrails,
people aren't gonna be
steadying themselves.
Like I'm gonna, this is
how I'm gonna go now,
because of this experience,
I'm gonna fall down something
No, but what I'm telling you
because I didn't want
to touch it.
Is that if everyone
does what you're doing,
it may actually make us
more susceptible to the next round,
because there will be another round.
I will have fallen down
stairs before that happens,
but yeah, as a society.
But it makes me think
differently about just flu season
in general, I don't
think about flu season.
And I know that comparisons
between COVID and flu
are unhelpful, very unhelpful.
But the fact is is that the seasonal flu,
if it's a bad one, kills
thousands of people,
well it kills people every year,
sometimes tens of thousands of people,
and I don't get the flu shot.
I mean, I very rarely get the flu shot.
And the reason I don't
get it is because I feel
personally invincible, so I think like,
"Oh, I might get the flu,
but it's not gonna kill me,
"I have to make an appointment."
But now I'm thinking about my own,
I'm not just thinking
about my own situation,
I'm thinking about how I
contribute to everyone's situation.
I never thought about the flu shot
Me getting the flu shot
In light of society service.
Is not about me, it's about society.
Getting the flu shot is
about the people who I might
come in contact with that are susceptible
and not being the a-hole, who's like,
"Oh, I might get the flu
and then I might interact
"with someone who's
susceptible and they die."
It's like, oh, that's a big change for me.
But I do think it's gonna also,
I think the greeting thing is a big thing.
Because there's currently an alternative.
And there's no way, there's zero chance
that shaking of hands and getting together
and getting really close to each other
in tight environments is gonna
be a regular thing in 2020,
like that's not coming back in 2020.
I'm not saying there
won't be some gatherings,
but it's not coming back soon.
I mean, when concerts and
going to the movies and parties
start happening again, boy, I think
there'll be a little bit of
time where we appreciate it.
And then there'll be a time
when we're old when we'll say,
"Oh, you know, you can go to
parties any time you want,
"but there was a time
when we couldn't do that.
"Couldn't party."
"It was a year."
"You had to party in your house."
"Couldn't party."
"On a video chat."
What about video chats?
How do you think video chats,
which are, I mean, everybody's
doing it, you gotta come
to grips with it.
I tend to enjoy
you more via video chat .
So I mean maybe we can conduct
our whole relationship like this.
You don't mean that,
that's just a funny thing
that you said.
I can't hear you chewing.
Interestingly, even though
you've got those earpods in--
What, I was eating cereal, last week
when we were doing the technical test,
I was eating cereal and you seemed
to be able to hear it viscerally.
Actually I could quite a bit.
For some reason, I could,
Because it's,
Oh, you know the reason
I couldn't really hear it
when we recorded that GMM
Earbuds.
You were drinking liquids,
you weren't chewing.
Yeah, I wasn't chewing it.
So I take that all back,
I'd rather be in person,
I'd rather be next to you.
I think it's good for
rela-, I think a whole group
of people, I think the majority of people
are realizing that they can conduct
a meaningful conversation
and a meaning relationship
on a screen.
Mmhmm.
And I just think that a lot of people
who were making phone calls before
are going to be making
video chats moving forward.
Well, think about the
video chat that we had
with our close friends from college.
We have been in contact,
loose contact, with these guys
who are like our best friends in college.
Many, many months,
For months via text.
Many, many months would go by
where we wouldn't, there
would be no contact at all.
But then we recently
reconnected and we started
a WhatsApp chat, and then during all this
since everyone has sort of
figured out the video chat thing,
we were like, let's do a Zoom call.
And nothing changed about our proximity.
It wasn't like we used to
be together like last year
and now we're apart.
It's like, no, we went
to college together,
but we got on and we had this,
you know, we talk to each other.
And I think people are getting over
the awkwardness of it.
The technological barrier like,
"I don't know how to do it,"
which everyone can do it at this point,
young and old can do it.
But also there's an awkwardness
to a video chat that,
That you get over.
I think everyone is being forced
to get over it really quickly.
Yeah, so I think it's
drastically accelerated
that type of relationship
and that type of connection.
I mean, I think about how
far I am from family members
and I just think that
there's a greater chance
of being more connected
when this thing is over
as a result of this, which is nice.
I mean the kids have started
schooling over video chats
and they're figuring all that out
and making sure they remember
that people can see them,
and that people can hear them
unless they turn their camera off.
It's this new awareness
of whenever I'm in front
of a screen people are
gonna start to assume
that they're being watched
versus the opposite,
'cause we're gonna learn that lesson.
Well and also the idea of people--
I think that's something we won't go back
and we'll have this comfort
level with being seen,
and heard, and basically watched
whenever we're on a screen.
It'll be the rule, not the exception.
But people are learning their lesson.
I don't know if you saw,
there was that Zoom chat
that the video, a portion
of the video from it,
went viral a couple weeks ago where it was
a work video chat and one
of the women on the call
has her computer and then all of a sudden
you see her get up and walk down the hall
and then all of a sudden
she sets the laptop down
on the bathroom floor,
the camera is pointing
right up at her, she pulls
in her pants and pees.
What?
Yes.
And you hear, the main
person who's talking
who's leading the discussion starts,
he slows down a little bit
and everybody starts looking
and covering their mouths
and laughing and stuff.
Why didn't they say,
"Hey Tina, pull up your britches, girl."
She looks down while she's
peeing and sees her legs
on the screen and then
suddenly closes the laptop.
Oh my gosh.
Another example, my dad was
in a call with some people
recently, like a Zoom call,
he and people in his 60s and 70s
who he's also having these meetings with.
They started, well his friend was like,
I'm hosting this Zoom
call and we're gonna start
the meeting at six
o'clock, but you can get
on the Zoom call at any time that you want
to just talk or whatever.
And my dad goes on there
at like four o'clock
just to check and make
sure everything's working
and he can hear this guy and his wife
having a conversation in their house
because they haven't muted themselves.
So I think one of the things
that's gonna happen is
people, there's this adjustment period,
people are gonna be caught
doing and saying things
about other people.
That thing that always happens
sometimes when you realize
that you're saying something about someone
that you wouldn't want them to hear
and then you're like, hold
on, did I accidentally
butt dial them right before this happened?
Or is this conference call muted.
Yeah.
Did I hit mute
or did I hit mute and
unmute really quickly
and now I'm saying something
that they're hearing.
Lily was watching this
TikTok sketch last night
and I happened to look over her shoulder
and it was some girl, of
course that she didn't know,
she wasn't dancing, she was
doing something comedic,
which is nice.
She was crying for the laughs.
Why is this girl crying?
Well then she goes on to
talk about how when you're
in your classroom chat if you
read the fine print it says,
well when you're in your video classroom
that the chat feature on the
side is permanently recorded
and the teacher can see that.
Not only can the teacher
see after the fact
the entire chat that's taken place,
they can also see the private messages
between students in the classroom.
On Zoom?
I actually don't,
Or on Google Classroom?
On Zoom.
I don't know which, and I
actually don't know if it's true
but she was making fun of it.
And I kinda can believe it.
But again, I don't know for sure.
That seems like a flaw in the
system if that's the case.
Well being able to see the classroom chat,
Well that seems right.
Later,
As the host.
Seems right.
But the private messages?
But direct messages?
They're just direct
messages between students.
It's like, yeah, should
a teacher be able to hear
what two students are
whispering to each other
in the back of the classroom?
No.
I don't think so.
Maybe.
I don't think so either.
So maybe she was wrong and
it's just sending shock waves
through TikTok and also to me.
You'd have to look into that
yourself but that's one thing.
Working from home, that's another thing.
First of all,
I do not like it.
I'm sure there are people
who are discovering
that they can work from
home, and they can get
everything done, and they can--
Those people don't have children.
Yeah, there's more freedom
associated with it or whatever.
I mean, it is gonna change
the workplace landscape,
there's gonna be, there's
savings associated with it,
depending on the business I guess.
Oh I think one of the biggest
changes that'll take place,
definitely people who have brutal commutes
will find ways to work from home.
Because a lot of people are instituting
work-from-home policies out of necessity,
now some businesses can't
continue to function
working from home, but a lot of 'em can.
And so those people who kinda discovered--
And once you find a way for
weeks, then you're like,
at least giving my Friday
at home and my Monday
kind of a thing.
It actually makes decisions, it can be
a beneficial thing for a lot of reasons
because you got somebody's
who's working from home,
therefore they're not driving,
so they're not contributing
carbon to the atmosphere
by driving but they're
also not wasting an hour,
or two hours, whatever,
just being on the road.
And so they've got more free
time and then the employer,
if that person doesn't
actually have to be present,
the employer doesn't have
to provide a space for them,
which means a smaller building.
There's definitely a
lot, but I think that one
of the practical ways
that it'll be implemented
is right now when you're
sick, one of the reasons
you stay home is because
you feel like crap,
another reason you stay home is
so you don't affect other people.
That is gonna happen a lot more.
People are gonna be like, I'm sick,
I actually think I could probably work,
but it would be irresponsible
for me to go in,
and also I can do my job
from home and I can go
into this meeting via videoconference.
Having people who are at
home sick or just needed
to stay home to do
something because they had
a doctor's appointment,
or because they needed
to watch their kid, suddenly those people
it's not gonna be weird to pipe
them in on a videoconference
because we will all have
the experience in doing it.
And it's not like, oh, the
person on the video chat
is somehow less of a
contributor or less significant
because we all remember
that time when we were all
on video chats.
I think that that's gonna
be a huge, huge change.
It's gonna change the way
sick leave is looked at
because you're gonna be able to stay home
and you're sick,
And work.
But you're still working,
and we're gonna have
to figure out what does that mean,
for hourly employees
what does that look like,
what does that mean?
All right and I'll shift it one more time
'cause I know you wanna talk about this,
so I'll just tee it up.
The view of science and scientists,
what they're saying to us.
I hope that that changes in a positive way
as a result of this.
Because if you look back weeks ago
at what science and scientists
were saying about what
most likely will happen
and now it is, and we
didn't wanna hear it,
we didn't wanna come to grips with it,
and so we opted for it to get worse
before we started to do enough.
I hope there's a lesson learned there
that translates into a silver lining.
Well there's definitely
a lesson learned there.
Okay, this has been
very discouraging to me,
this has been incredibly
infuriating honestly.
Now I've been infuriated with people
who refuse to listen to plain
science for a long time,
but the timescale of what we knew
and then how we could,
everything has been condensed
and clarified in this situation.
Now, this is a distinct,
it's not distinctly
but it is very much an American issue.
I can't imagine what the rest
of the world is thinking,
they're like, you guys,
there's so much pride
in being an American, but yet
what we lead the world in,
in many ways, is just
almost aggressive ignorance.
We're really the only place
in the world right now
that's experiencing this
pandemic to this degree
where people, the general population,
has a distinctly polarized
opinion about what's
actually happening because
of the political polarization
in our country, which is
just mind-blowing to me.
Now, more and more people
who played it down,
including our president, are
coming around to the reality
and beginning to listen to
the people who said this
all along, but the things
that I've heard like--
And it's taken bodies
in refrigerated trucks
outside of hospitals for that to happen.
Yeah, right, but the thing is is that--
And I just wanna redeem that,
I wanna redeem those bodies.
I want to know that we won't
make these mistakes again.
Go ahead.
But I think that,
okay, there's lots of people
saying that no one knew
this was gonna happen, I've
heard that so many times.
No one could have known
this was happening.
What, are you freaking nuts?
No, we've been being warned about this
from so many people for so many years
that this exact scenario
with this exact timeline
with the exact exponential
curve of infections and deaths,
even where it potentially would come from,
like all this was very
much written on the wall,
said in TED Talks, written in
books, written in articles,
and anyone who was paying
attention even a little bit
should not have been surprised by this.
But in one sense, it's very
difficult to be prepared
because if you think about it
from a political standpoint,
it would be very difficult,
especially in our country,
to convince people that
disaster preparedness
on this level for a pandemic
was worth investing in, right.
It's like everyone's
struggling to figure out
what we're gonna do with our
money if somebody was like,
guys, we're gonna have a surplus
of masks and ventilators,
are you gonna get votes for that?
No, everyone's gonna
be like, you're crazy,
why are you spending all
that money on something
that might not happen?
So it took a--
Probably won't happen
I think is the way
It took an event like this,
but the thing is
They'd say it.
Because what we're
talking about is I think
in America there is this
distrust of authority,
which is a good thing, right,
but there is a distrust of
expertise, which is a bad thing,
and people have lumped them together.
So the whole idea of
questioning authority,
people have talked like you
could never do a lockdown
in the US like you did in
China because we don't have
an authoritarian government.
And also the whole
point, like the principal
founding principle of
America is independence
from an oppressive government, right.
And so I think that
that's a healthy thing,
I think that questioning authority,
there's a healthy,
positive place for that.
But in the past generation or so,
that has gotten conflated
with questioning expertise
and thinking that people who
are experts in certain areas,
scientists namely, are part
of a deep-state conspiracy
on all sorts of issues.
But again, they've been saying
it from the very beginning,
they were like, okay, this
is when it's gonna get here.
There was literally a dude who said
this will be beginning to
infect large numbers of people
in the US the week of March
so and so or whatever,
he said that in January.
And you know what happened,
that week is the week
that it was like, oh,
now we've got clusters,
we've got community spread.
Is he a prophet, does
he have a crystal ball?
No, he just has studied this before
but that doesn't keep a
bunch of stupid-ass people
from going on Facebook and
talking about something
they have no idea about.
Like the amount of
drivel that has come out
of people's mouths and
off of people's keyboards,
these armchair experts,
it's like I don't know
about this stuff, I'm not
gonna claim to know about it,
I haven't read these books,
I haven't studied this,
but I can recognize when someone has
and understand that, oh,
they're all saying basically
the same thing, there may
be a range of projections,
but they're all basically
saying the same thing.
They're all saying this is gonna seem
like we're overreacting,
but just trust us,
these things operate according
to very established
principles, very established
mathematical projections,
and this is what's
going to happen and here's what we have
to do to minimize that.
And now one of the things
I'm already seeing is
just because the
projections have come down
people are like, "I told
you the experts were wrong.
"They said that two million
people were gonna die
"and now they're saying
that 200,000 are gonna die.
"See, science fails again."
It makes me want to harm
someone when I hear people
say things like that.
'Cause the simple reality
is the projections
have changed because the practices
that the experts suggested
are being implemented.
We want the projections to change.
And some people, and some
governors, and some leaders
have actually said we're
actually going to get ahead
of this and we're going
to institute these things
before they become a huge problem.
We want the projections
to change because we want
people to actually do what
the experts are suggesting.
But again, there is this
tendency to question,
to be like, I think I
might know more than this
because I have a communications degree.
I don't understand.
It's not just Southern people who have
these opinions, by the way.
Well, the reason I go
into that Southern accent
is because that's where I'm
from and where I'm from,
that's the best way to
characterize that mentality.
As a Southern man with a southern accent,
I have the right to go
into a Southern accent
to make fun of people and I stand by that
until it becomes offensive
in 2025, then I'll stop.
Is that another prediction?
But can any positive come from this?
I think that's--
Well, of course, yeah, yeah.
A couple people have, this
isn't something I came up with,
a number of people have
made this connection,
but this is there's very little difference
between this and climate change, right.
Again, in America, it's
the only nation on Earth
where there is a legitimate, large section
of the population that doubts the reality
of manmade climate change,
that humans are causing climate change
and also climate change
stands the potential
to be catastrophic and
we're already beginning
to see the effects, right.
There's a huge group of
people driven by not science
but ideology who think that
this is just all a scam.
When the people who
have devoted their lives
to studying this, who are
not part of a deep-state
conspiracy, who are just
people who are after the truth,
have been sounding the warning bells
and they've said this is
what's going to happen,
these are the projections, this
is the worst-case scenario,
this is the best-case scenario,
but this is the range of scenarios
based on what we're doing right now.
And if we don't adopt
these drastic measures,
then this many people could die.
Now it's not as precise
and it's not as short-term
as the COVID-19 thing, but it's all
the same factors are in play.
You got people who don't know
anything about the situation
who go on a website and
find some information
and then parrot it on
Facebook and everybody,
there's so much false
information that is parroted.
There is this idea that people who believe
in climate change are part
of a deep-state conspiracy.
There's a lot of people who are like,
even if climate change is
real, we can't implement
the measures that the
scientists are suggesting
because it'll kill our economy.
Again, another thing that is
perfectly in line with COVID-19.
And maybe, just maybe,
and again like you said,
it's taking people being
in refrigerated trucks
for people to see this, these
guys who were not motivated
by anything other than
a desire to understand
and communicate the truth
have been saying this,
have been warning us, and
here's what's happening.
See, what we said was
gonna happen is happening,
and how to prevent it
is exactly how we said
we should prevent it, and yes,
it is going to negatively affect
the economy to some degree
but we'll get through
it and we will recover.
The same principles are in play.
I would love to think
that we as humans are,
and especially as Americans,
are learning our lesson
to listen to the scientists
and to take action,
to take drastic action for
something that's happening,
drastic things are happening.
You see glaciers melting,
who cares.
You show the sad polar bear,
Hey, it's cyclical, man, it's cyclical.
The wildfires, all the natural disasters,
I'm just afraid that not enough people
are going to learn a lesson from this to--
Well, here's the great news.
You don't have to have a lot
of them learn their lesson.
You just have to have
enough to change policy.
That's the beautiful
thing about our country
is you don't have to
have 98% of people agree,
right now, we have a political
ideology in this country
that while there are some
healthy questioning authority
things that come from that ideology,
some other things have
been glommed onto it,
including this distrust of expertise.
And so that group of
people are driving policy
and keeping real change from happening.
But we were almost there,
we were almost there
as a country, both parties
were kind of aligned
and said this is a real deal,
we need to take some action,
and then 2016 happened and a lot of things
are moving in the wrong direction.
But what I'm getting at is
I feel like this is going to
impact some people's mentality to be like,
hmm, maybe I shouldn't just read a book
or go on a website and just suddenly think
that 97% of the people
who study this are wrong.
I just don't know how
catastrophic this needs to be,
and it already is in many ways,
people's lives are
wrecked, people are dying,
people's livelihoods are disintegrating,
but I don't know how bad it needs to get
for it to really shake us up
permanently in order to be
able to apply these
lessons to climate change.
Because it's so applicable,
but I'm just afraid that,
I don't know, 'cause the worse it gets,
the more money we're gonna have to spend
and band together in order
to rebuild the economy.
Are we gonna wanna turn
around and also spend
a lot of money to, you know,
all the support structures
we're putting in place to get everyone
back on their feet and to get
the economy back on its feet
are things that are part
of the Green New Deal
to accommodate for people
who are in industries
which are harming the
environment in order to give them
a support structure to continue to be
a contributing part of
the economy and society
and for their livelihood
not to disintegrate.
So it's just you're gonna
spend a lot of money
to fix this problem of COVID-19,
is there gonna be any
money left over to spend
on this initiative that like, by the way,
it's not something that's
predicted that might happen,
it also is happening.
That's something, again,
the president keeps saying
hopefully this won't
happen again for centuries,
it's like, dude, what?
It's going to happen
again, we knew that it was
going to happen, they said
it was going to happen,
and it will happen again.
And it will happen more often, actually,
the more we continue to grow,
and there's more people,
and that we're more crowded.
Travel and connections, I
mean it's a lot different
than it was 100 years ago.
But I think that the good
news, something that we can
be hopeful about of what you said
is that, first of all,
there are things happening
as a result of this virus
that directly impact
carbon emissions, right.
And I'm not just talking about
factories being shut down,
or all the sudden there's
no tourism in Venice, Italy
so the canals are clear for the
first time in recent memory.
That's not a sustainable
thing, we don't want there
to be no tourists, we
want people to travel,
we want people to make things, we do want
the economy to come back.
But something as simple
as thinking differently
about consumerism and consumption
that is going to have an
impact on just the amount
of goods that are produced
and what we think we actually need.
And I think that that is gonna have
a positive impact on climate.
These supply chains being so global,
which I think it's great that
we're connected as humans
and the imaginary borders
that we place around ourselves
we're beginning to see
that they are just that,
they're imaginary, you
can't keep the virus out,
the virus doesn't know
that there's a border
around your country, doesn't see people
the way that people see people.
But we necessarily will
have to move manufacturing
closer to the people who
need those manufactured goods
and that is going to
have a drastic impact.
'Cause basically when all this
stuff got outsourced globally
and all the stuff is being
produced in mass quantities
and then shipped all around the world,
all of that has increased
carbon emissions drastically,
but if we bring those supply
chains back closer to home,
it'll be good for local
economies, it'll be good
for the environment, so I think that part
of the economic recovery because of this
could actually have some of those
green technologies and strategies,
which ultimately will
in the long term make us
healthier as an economy and be able
to address the pressing
problems of climate change.
I'm trying to be hopeful.
There is hope, Link.
I'm trying to be positive.
That is the exercise.
I mean, that is the
challenge for all of us
is to whether we're looking to the future
or looking to the next
five minutes is that
we need to continue, and
I'm shifting gears here
in order to conclude this
thing, it's our challenge
to remain positive and
to channel our energy
into things that enrich
our lives and the lives of other people.
So how many weeks is this gonna go on?
I don't know, we're gonna keep having
these discussions every
week, be a part of it,
#EarBiscuits, let us know what you think
about these life
predictions that we've made.
But also I just want to
take it as an opportunity
to encourage you to love yourself
and love those around you
and that includes the people
around you via video chat,
to just channel your energy into things
that enrich your lives
and the lives of others.
And continue to find the silver linings.
I think with where we are, I don't know
that we did a great job of it today.
I tend to have this frus-,
like when I think about
everything we've been
talking about there's still
a lot of frustration that's coming out,
it's hard to have a
lighthearted discussion
when these things are going on,
and I think that's the reality of it.
I think these things,
it's good to be frustrated
about these things
because we deserved better
than the response that we've gotten
and people should have
been more responsible.
People should have
listened to the experts.
You shouldn't have to see people die
in order to believe that
someone who has devoted
their lives to studying
something that is pretty well
understood were telling you the truth.
So it is something to get upset about.
Because listen, people, that mentality,
the mentality of not believing experts
has directly led to an untold
number of deaths already
and it will continue
to lead to more deaths.
So that's worth being upset about,
it's okay to be upset about that.
But again, like you
said, Joe Diffie's death
will not be in vain because
ironically when people see
that these people that they looked up to,
that they loved, die, whether they be,
everyone will known someone
who suffered from this
and many people will know
someone who died personally
but you'll also people
who have created things
that you love are gonna die from this.
And I think little by
little it's sinking in
to more and more people and there's no way
that that can't have some sort
of charitable impact on people.
It won't be all in vain.
I'll give a recommendation, it's my week.
If you haven't hunkered down and watched
"Lord of the Rings," get your
hand on the extended versions.
The longer the movie, the better.
The versions that we watched
weren't the extended ones
and then we started watching
the extras, which is
my actual recommendation
'cause we've already made
the recommendation of the movies.
My family's going through the extras now.
But do you know how long
the extended version
of "Return of the King" is?
Let's see, it goes
'Cause I do.
from three hours to three and a half?
It's four hours and 52 minutes.
What?
I bought it last night.
I had the DVD set extended
edition and you know me,
I've cleaned out so much
stuff over the past few years
and I just get so aggressive.
I got rid of 'em because
they weren't blu-ray
and I was like I can just rent 'em online.
Well it turns out you
can't, you have to buy
the extended version,
especially if you wanna see
all the extras, you can
see some of 'em on YouTube,
which we've watched, but
they're varying quality.
I don't know how you get your
kids to sit through that.
They love it.
My kids, Christy doesn't watch it,
but my kids love these extras.
My kids love the movies.
There's like 15 hours of extras.
Well no, but I'm talking
about the length of the movie.
My kids love the movies,
but then we'll be getting
into the third hour, and they're like,
"How long is this movie, Dad?"
Like it isn't like I'm
ready to stop watching it,
but it's like they don't watch
things that are that long
and the idea of them watching a movie
for four hours and 52 minutes?
Well, I would divide it
up into three sittings,
which you have, again, you can do that.
But my kids are really getting
hooked on the production.
Like I think they're all wanting
to be movie producers now.
May change their mind next week.
It's the most in-depth,
behind-the-scenes footage
of any movie and there's
no movie as worthy of it
as "Lord of the Rings" in my opinion.
So I think it's worth
the $50 to buy the whole,
and make sure you get
the extended version,
not the theatrical version,
when you buy the blu-ray DVDs
so that you get the extended scenes
as well as the extras.
That's my rec, man, #EarBiscuits.
Yeah, we'll keep talking and we're not,
we promise that we're
not gonna keep talking
about the virus, there
are other things happening
and there's other things to talk about.
So we'll talk about something
different next week.
Or maybe we won't, I don't know what
we're gonna talk about next week.
Well, but we'lL also invite
you into the conversation,
'cause I really enjoyed when we talked
about everybody's secret hobbies
or whatever it was that we talked about.
We're gonna have something different,
but we will keep talking
about this as long
as we're doing it, but
we're not gonna do it
next week, we'll take a
break from the heavy stuff.
But we will do an episode, so we'll talk
at you next week.
Yes we will,
every week, every week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.